hong kong voto en unas elecciones
criticadas por los grupos prodemocracia
ya que consideran que beneficia a china
y a los llamados patriotas leales al
gobierno de beijing se trata de unos
comicios en los que participaron cerca
de 4.900 hongkoneses en una ciudad con
una población de 75 millones de
habitantes
con el objetivo de mejorar el sistema
electoral de la región administrativa
especial de hong kong es garantizar que
los patriotas administren hong kong
este es un objetivo muy legítimo de
cualquier elección pública en cualquier
gobierno
tras la selección de los 364 escaños de
los 1500 miembros del comité electoral
este organismo se encargará de elegir en
diciembre a 40 de los 90 legisladores de
la ciudad y en marzo del próximo año al
sucesor del ejecutivo hongkonés pero las
voces críticas contra el renovado
sistema electoral de hong kong apuntan a
decir que la oposición ha sido excluida
y no faltan voces diversas o de
oposición dentro de las elecciones damos
la bienvenida a legisladores de
diferentes campos políticos siempre y
cuando apoye la constitución la ley
básica y sean leales a la región
administrativa especial de hong kong
luego de que el centro financiero dejó
de estar bajo dominio británico china
prometió que mantendría sus libertades
fundamentales y autonomía sin embargo
las protestas en 2019 a favor de la
democracia fueron una alerta para
beijing lo que llevó a china a imponer
una serie de medidas en su sistema
político una dura ley de seguridad
nacional y mandar a prisión a decenas de
activistas